regardez cette synchro dans les jambes
sont synchro
mais ça dure 1000 ans madame porte des
talons Joe Biden qui est au côté
d'Emmanuel Macron au coin du feu dans le
bureau Val de la Maison Blanche on va
peut-être découvrir cette image la voilà
entretien bilatéral France États-Unis
sachez qu'hier les deux couples ont dîné
dans un restaurant italien un moment
immortalisé par cette photo mise en
ligne par Joe Biden sur son compte
Twitter le président américain et le
président français qui effectueront une
conférence de presse cet après-midi
c'est le temps fort de cette visite
d'État côté boisson vous pourrez
accompagner tout ça dans le calendrier
de l'avent rempli de bière artisanales
on a aussi les petites fioles de vin
vous avez la version luxe un calendrier
géant qui contient des bouteilles de
champagne et de vin comptait quand même
1500 euros pour le calendrier et
d'ailleurs c'est pas recommandé
dans un moment très important
celui ou une autre baguette a été
reconnu patrimoine immatériel
de l'UNESCO dans ces quelques
centimètres de savoir-faire passer de
main en main
il y a il y a exactement l'esprit du
savoir-faire français je sais pas si il
y a donné sa maman à manger mais c'est
trop quand c'est trop c'est trop piquant
quoi il faut qu'il arrête au bout d'un
moment là
ça paraît être juste matériel
mais non non mais la baguette représente
ça beaucoup ont essayé de le faire ils
ont fait un truc industriel qui n'a pas
de goût
une part de flan
Pipo et oui il fait du flan et
d'ailleurs on fait de la clarinette
depuis peu
suffisant que pour éviter les poursuites
en justice ce genre de trucs
[Rires]
certains viennent tous les weekends
beaucoup ont refusé que nous les
filmions
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
près le live les fameuses rencontres
dédicaces qui seraient jugées très
choquantes en France
bonsoir Laurent et je suis démineur
vous vous déterrez des bombes non non je
suis démineur dans la rue
près des écoles pourtant les règles sont
strictes interdit de demander un numéro
de téléphone ou de se voir ailleurs ce
sont des amours platoniques
pourquoi tu n'es pas amoureux de moi
mais je le suis déjà vraiment sur tes
réseaux j'ai bien vu que tu avais mis la
photo d'une autre idole
le dernier message chelou que vous ayez
reçu sur les réseaux sociaux ah bah
assez régulièrement me demande de
montrer mes pieds
ça marche plus un peu le business et
tout on va te faire
ici j'ai l'impression de venir voir ma
famille bienvenue en famille
[Rires]
je suis pas dans la vieille tente
rabat-joie pas encore en train de on est
en train de vibrer bonsoir
a commencé alors on vous entend pas mon
chéri parce que on t'entend pas mon
chéri parce que en fait il y a pas de
micro
un jeune homme de 27 ans a réussi à
s'introduire dans l'enceinte du palais
c'était fin septembre arrêté sur le
perron il a déjoué les contrôles il n'y
aura pas de suite judiciaire mais on a
donc des précisions ce matin Rémi ink
pour RMC des précisions parce qu'il
cherchait du travail il a donc traversé
la rue pour voir le Président je me suis
dit que ça serait encore mieux de venir
postuler directement pour montrer mes
qualités humaines voilà ce qui explique
cet homme de 27 ans son CV à la main
alors t'inquiète pas on t'en veux pas
mon chéri qu'est-ce qui se passe
parce qu'on entend pas en fait voilà
pas partout je fais des vidéos à gauche
à droite tu sais tu t'incrustes un peu
partout comme eux
tu peux venir nous faire tu viens nous
le faire tu veux nous le faire là
vas-y je vais te dire c'est certainement
plus intéressant
[Applaudissements]
barricadé j'ai vu une autre porte
explique-t-il il y voit des personnes
entrées et sortir librement en tenue
civile de là j'ai suivi deux personnes
tout simplement ils croisent de regarde
un gendarme mais aucun contrôle aucune
demande alors il continue son avancée
dans le plus grand des calmes pour
arriver dans la cour d'honneur de la 7e
puissance du monde un maître d'hôtel
vérifie son identité le fait patienter
puis des membres de la sécurité l'escort
enfin hors du palais frère
en fait ça part d'un constat qui est
très simple si j'ai réalisé que chez moi
il y a pas de miroir que je supporte pas
les miroirs et que en fait j'ai beaucoup
de mal avec mon image dès que je tombe
sur moi par hasard à la télé je zappe
direct dès que je tombe par hasard sur
moi dans un film je zappe direct je me
suis dit que c'est un truc que d'artiste
ou est-ce que c'est un truc pour
quelques mois ouais du coup j'ai appelé
Gad Elmaleh je lui ai demandé si c'était
la même chose pour lui et il m'a dit il
m'a dit ouais ouais il m'a dit moi
chaque fois que je tombe sur toi je
zappe direct aussi
dans les années 60 les spectateurs la
retrouve dans de nombreuses comédies
d'aventure
Fantômas contre Scotland garde c'est
aussi le charme avec Mylène Demongeot
vous m'avez outre
je vous jure que non alors là il faut
que je la vois pas perdre on va s'aimer
sur une étoile c'est pas lui c'est super
Voltali qui chante
pendant 30 ans elle partagera la vie du
réalisateur et photographe maximum pour
lequel elle mettra sa carrière au second
plan ces dernières années Mylène
Demongeot multiplié les prises de
position notamment pour le droit à
mourir dans la dignité tolérer en Suisse
et de l'erreur en Belgique c'est les
Luxembourg pourquoi est-ce qu'elle est
toujours en retard dans ce pays Mylène
de mon jour est décédé aujourd'hui à 87
ans